hey guys how's it going so today's gonna
be a small different type of video I got
this on Amazon is a blood typing it kit
know your blood type I do not know my
blood type and a lot of you guys already
know that I don't know it because I
tried this video once before but I was a
little baby and I couldn't prick myself
the needle and I screwed it up and then
I took the test and I realized that my
blood type was not the right blood type
and I called my mom and tore that I was
not her daughter and she's like Justine
yes you are because I saw you come out
and I took your home and I was like not
a are you sure I'm yours and she said
yes so I'm gonna take it again so here
we go I got two of them just in case of
screwed up so inside of the kit alrighty
all right already oh this scares me all
these things okay directions home
kitchen I love how much blood am I gonna
need step one kind of in the envelope
and write your name on the part I'm not
going to write my name on the card
because I know my name and I'm the only
person taking it so shut up
scissors opening up the card here it is
this is it fill a glass of water
suck a small amount of water into the
pipette interval where's my pipette
where's my pipe where's my pipette fill
the glass with water suck a small amount
of water and release one drop on each of
the colored of region spots on the card
how many drops did you say am i seeing
me bowling no Hayden
oh we're turning it all the way up a
pancake keep your arm down for 10
seconds to stimulate the blood flow
wait ah man act let's do this let's do
this I don't want the pinched okay got
my sticks ready ready for the pinch ow
hey I got this not enough blood that's
not enough that's not enough that's not
enough i clot too quickly I think I
failed again guys I'm like a clotting
factory a factory of clot
I'll never know what my blood type is
this sucks
I caught so quickly look it's already
disappeared this is so sad
look at my little test I screwed this up
yeah I don't have enough blood for the
next two out now my finger hurts this is
dumb I don't want to do this anymore and
I think I don't like this game this game
of life I think I'm just gonna have to
go give some blood so they can tell me
what I enema I did not have a good time
doing this well on this disappointing
note I don't even know what to say
I have no results I didn't like the
pinch so I'm not gonna do it again if
you guys know your blood type let me
know in the comments below what you guys
are i am a well I'm a failure in
addition to letting me know what your
blood type is feel free to let me know
what kind of video you'd like to see me
make next and please can make sure to
does not involve any more pinching of
the skin because that was not fun now I
need to go to Disney and have fun mill
your blood side do I know my blood type
oh I don't know because this test is not
fun
I'm good
[Music]